isayama the author of attack on titan
said before how reiner is his favorite
character
and as most anime only watchers are
seeing now he's complex
comparable to the tragic hero archetype
made up in greek literature
and what's even more impressive is this
same reflection of traits we see in
aaron as well
both characters who have fallen from
grace and resorted to desperation
or less than ideal options to deal with
what they've been given
today i'm going to examine how similar
these characters are how this
resemblance reinforces one of attack on
titan's main themes
that there are no cut and clear villains
in the world
everyone is evil in their own way looked
at through a different lens
and how they choose to express that evil
is what truly separates humans from one
another
before we get into it if you like attack
on titan anime or manga
subscribing would be a huge help for the
growing channel enjoy the video
reiner and aaron both began from rather
humble beginnings with really only one
goal in mind when they joined the survey
corps and the warrior candidate program
respectively
to be the hero that saves humanity
errands could be done by killing all the
titans and reiners by retaking paradise
island
both of which were initially rooted in
very human desires case-elected species
in evolutionary terms are species such
as humans where the parents produce few
offspring but
invest significant parental care into
their child's growth
aaron wanted to avenge his mother he
wanted to see the titans the devils in
his eyes
killed who took her from him reiner
wanted to protect his mother make her
proud
retaking paradise island becoming an
honorable titan shifter
beating the devils on paradise island
would reciprocate the care his mother
put into him as a child
and so both characters are made out to
be innately human
down to their dna and genomic history an
important trait to have when you're
constantly compared to the
of course more valuable to society
titans that they both carry
both characters reiner more explicitly
than aaron were valued mainly by the
titan they carried
and though reiner's value is more
obvious as an honorary marlian aaron is
also
often using the military only for his
titan power before being considered a
human
being a scary old titan is first and
foremost
and so i don't think their descent into
feeling alone and isolated from society
is unexpected
in fact i think they were meant to take
on the role of the invader from the
start
reiner was the one that pushed annie and
berthold to finish the mission
he was so desperate to make himself into
an honorary marlin
and after witnessing grisha's memories
in the battle of shingon china seen in
these last moments of season 3
and in the recent episode of season 4
it's clear that aaron was the one to
spur the invasion of marley
the two who have never been
wholeheartedly accepted as human in
society
despite having such human desires to
start off with were the ones who pushed
themselves to become the villain
and to do so they both had to betray
their friends i think the reason reiner
is more of a tragic character
is because it really does feel like he
struggled with having to betray the
survey corps
aaron doesn't look very sympathetic here
but i think this betrayal of fellow
humans people who are the same as you
took something from each character's
humanity aaron is repeating history
doing to the marlins exactly what they
did to him as a child
coming back to the idea that everyone
can be a villain in someone else's eyes
and the irony lies in the fact that both
of these characters who were never
treated as human
finally embraced it they became the
villain that everyone wanted to see them
as
and that's what's truly tragic about
both of them
[Music]
and though aaron doesn't show regret now
i doubt that his fate will end up very
different from rhinos
it's very intentionally made that the
characters mirror each other that aaron
calls rhino to the basement before he
enacts the invasion that reiner did to
his people so many years ago
we're left to wonder whether aaron
calling reiner to the basement was an
act of cruelty
or an act of sympathy it's cruel in the
sense that aaron is torturing reiner
with his own past repeating what reiner
did to him
but you can see it as sympathy as pity
in the fact that aaron is giving reiner
the warning
the notice of what he's going to do
beforehand that aaron never got as a
child
just like reiner says to falco titan
shifters have a terrible fate
and i think that in aaron and reiner's
twin pursuits of being heroes of
protecting their families
they have lost that piece of humanity
that gave them their first push
to begin with the end they will both
reach will teach us that repeating
history
invading each other and becoming a new
villain each time will not bring
fruitful results
it'll only bring tragedy something that
both of these characters know
all too well as always this has been the
anime culture corner i hope you enjoyed
the video
don't forget to like and subscribe for
future in-depth show manga and character
analyses
you